en colombia los asesinatos de líderes
sociales y defensores de derechos
humanos marcan un nuevo récord 122
personas asesinadas entre el 1 de enero
y el 31 de julio un aumento frente a
años anteriores son las cifras oficiales
de la defensoría del pueblo que hizo un
llamado al gobierno los homicidios
contra líderes sociales y personas
defensoras de derechos humanos
representan una grave afectación en
contra de las comunidades y la
democracia por esta razón debemos desde
el estado brindarles las garantías
necesarias para el ejercicio de su labor
ya que es vital para garantizar el
bienestar y los derechos humanos de las
regiones según el reporte oficial los
líderes comunales representan 33 casos
por muertes violentas el 93% de las
víctimas eran hombres el departamento
del cauca en el suroeste del país
continúa siendo el más letal para estos
defensores con 19 homicidios seguido de
nariño antioquia y putumayo en estas
mismas regiones los grupos armados se
disputan el control por las rutas del
narcotráfico y el territorio para las
plantaciones de cultivos ilícitos o la
minería ilegal amedrentando violentando
y desplazando a las comunidades locales
y humanas words y al presidente gustavo
petro 5 recomendaciones para el éxito de
la paz total una de las consignas del
nuevo mandatario garantizar protección y
seguridad en los territorios decidir con
quién negociar y de qué manera abordar
las causas que perpetúan la violencia
garantizar los derechos de las víctimas
evitar desmovilizaciones fraudulentas
por su parte petro ordenó la semana
pasada a la fuerza pública que vele por
neutralizar al máximo la comisión de
masacres y muertes de líderes sociales
al tiempo que reinicia los diálogos con
la guerrilla de ln en un intento por
acabar con la violencia en colombia